So first we're going to make a pandas
data frame. Again, I'm going to call it hr year.
That will read in hr by team year sf
ls.csv. Then we'll create our ggplot. So we'll say
print ggplot hr year, and note that we say
aes yearID, HR, and then we set color equal
to teamID. Then we're going to add geometric points
and geometric lines, but not pass on a color.
Otherwise this is very similar to our basic plot, which
didn't have different lines and points for different teams. Let's
see what this creates when we actually run it. As
you can see we have here a chart which compares the
total number of home runs hit per year, for the
L.A. Dodgers, called here LAN for LA National League. And
the San Francisco Giants, called here SFN for San Francisco
National League. We have two different sets of points and lines
which are color coded according to team, and we're able to compare how the
total number of home runs hit have varied by year for the two teams.